[Music]
one simple vitamin can reduce your risk
of heart disease eating chocolate
reduces stress in students new drug
prolongs lives of patients with rare
disease health headlines like these are
published every day sometimes making
opposite plans from each other there
going to be a disconnect between broad
attention grabbing headlines and the
often specific incremental results of
the medical research they cover so how
can you avoid being misled by grabbing
headlines the best way to assess a
headlines credibility is to look at the
original research it reports on we've
come up with a hypothetical research
scenario for each of these three
headlines keep watching for the
explanation of the first example then
pause at the headline to answer the
question
these are simplified scenarios a real
study would detail many more factors and
how to account for them but for the
purposes of this exercise assume all the
information you need is included let's
start by considering the cardiovascular
effects of a certain vitamin healthy 'm
the study finds that participants taking
a healthy amalfi cholesterol than those
taking a placebo their levels became
similar to those of people with
naturally high levels of this kind of
cholesterol previous research has shown
that people with naturally high levels
of healthy cholesterol have lower rates
of heart disease so what makes this
headline misleading healthy 'm reduces
risk of heart disease the problem with
this headline is that the research
didn't actually investigate whether
healthy 'm reduces heart disease it only
measured healthiest impact on levels of
a particular kind of cholesterol the
fact that people with naturally high
levels of that cholesterol have lower
risk of heart attacks doesn't mean that
the same will be true of people who
elevate their cholesterol levels using
healthy 'm now that you've cracked the
case of healthy 'm try your hand at a
particularly alluring mystery the
relationship between eating chocolate
and stress
this hypothetical study recruits 10
students half begin consuming a daily
dose of chocolate while half abstain as
classmates they all follow the same
schedule by the end of the study the
chocolate eaters are less stressed than
their chocolate free counterparts what's
wrong with this headline eating
chocolate reduces stress in students
it's a stretch to draw a conclusion
about students in general from a sample
of 10 that's because the fewer
participants are in a random sample the
less likely it is that the sample will
closely represent the target population
as a whole
for example if the broader population of
students is half male and half female
the chance of drawing a sample of 10
that skewed 70% male and 30% female is
about 12% in a sample of 100 that would
be less than a point zero zero two five
percent chance and for a sample of 1,000
the odds are less than six times 10 to
the negative thirty sixth power
similarly with fewer participants each
individual's outcome has a larger impact
on the overall results and can therefore
skew big-picture trends still there are
a lot of good reasons for scientists to
run small studies by starting with a
small sample they can evaluate whether
the results are promising enough to run
a more comprehensive expensive study and
some research requires very specific
participants that may be impossible to
recruit in large numbers the key is a
reproducibility if an article draws a
conclusion from one small study that
conclusion may be suspect but if it's
based on many studies that have found
similar results it's more credible we've
still got one more puzzle in this
scenario a study tests a new drug for a
rare fatal disease in a sample of 2,000
patients the ones who start taking the
drug upon diagnosis live longer than
those who take the placebo this time the
question is slightly different what's
one more thing you'd like to know before
deciding if the headline new drug
prolongs lives of patients with Ray
disease is justified before making this
call you'd want to know how much the
drug prolonged the patient's lives
sometimes a study can have results that
while scientifically valid don't have
much bearing on real-world outcomes for
example one real-life clinical trial of
a pancreatic cancer drug found an
increase in life expectancy of 10 days
the next time you see a surprising
medical headline to take a look at the
science it's reporting on even when full
papers aren't available without a fee
you can often find summaries of
experimental design and results in
freely available abstracts or even
within the text of a news article it's
exciting to see scientific research
covered in the news and important to
understand the study's findings keep
honing your headline hacking skills with
this video
[Music]